now I'd like to introduce today's speech
speaker Pamela Matson professor Matson
is Dean of the Stanford School of earth
energy and environmental sciences as
well as an internationally recognized
interdisciplinary earth scientist
academic leader and organizational
strategist her research focuses on the
consequences of agricultural
intensification land-use change
and nitrogen deposition for ecosystems
and the atmosphere and on sustainable
development issues in developing regions
working mostly in the tropics she and
her colleagues have identified the
negative consequences of deforestation
and intensive agriculture for the global
and local atmosphere freshwater and
marine marine systems and are working to
develop new approaches that reduce those
impacts while maintaining human
livelihood and well-being she also works
on the vulnerability of food and water
systems to climate change and with that
I'd like to turn it over to Pam welcome
well welcome thank you very much for
being here I'm glad to have a chance to
talk with you this morning I'd like to
talk about a framework and an approach
for pursuing sustainability and what I'm
going to do is start with a little bit
about motivation why would we be doing
this why do we care and then provide a
framework for analysis and decision
making a framework that really anyone
any leader could use I'll talk a little
bit about why this is really hard and
then add a bit about the tools that we
can use to help make good decisions for
sustainability so first of all of you
let me start with the question there we
go let me tell me adjust it the question
what does sustainability mean of course
this is the term that's used by many
different people in many different
situations and have different meanings
but there are a couple that matter to us
in this context it really emerged
initially from the UN and from an
ongoing discussion about how to help the
poorest countries in the world's develop
and develop well socially and
economically going back to the
Brundtland
port in 1989 our common future basically
said look if we're going to meet the
needs of people we're going to be
working on that very very hard right now
how do we do that and still not forego
our opportunities for the future not
compromise the future ability of people
to meet their own needs and that is them
work down very very hard over many
decades today we have a new set of
sustainable development goals that the
UN put together last year through it an
engaged stakeholder set set of
discussions and people and organizations
and institutions around the world are
working toward those goals so that's
sustainable development but now what
about corporate sustainability this is
another major emphasis that has has
engaged lots of corporations around the
world over the last couple of decades we
think about the three-legged stool or
the triple bottom line or the three E's
to represent the fact that corporations
are now trying to make decisions that
make sense economically in terms of
profit but also socially and
environmentally and in many ways this is
is now relevant to the Eest value system
that many corporations are placing on
their operations so why do businesses
engage in this lots of reasons a lot of
reasons having to do with internal
business sustainability with the
well-being of the company for in both
the short and the long term a lots of
companies have engaged for efficiency
savings they've staged a lot of money by
using resources more efficiently many
are identifying growth opportunities in
new markets that are related to using
scarce resources more effectively for
humans and human needs their
reputational issues is certainly one way
to attract recruit and retain motivated
employees who care about about the world
and lots of elements of risk management
but I think increasingly corporations
are
are buying into this are engaging in
this because they are concerned
Bayonetta leaders are concerned about
the well-being of people beyond their
own corporation so it's about well-being
in that in both cases and so I think we
can in a sense define sustainability as
with the goal of a well-being of people
today and in the future of companies in
this next quarter but in the longer term
and of institutions and organizations
and people here but also all around the
world that's the definition we're using
for sustainability goal so we're talking
about then well-being and then we can
ask a question what is well-being means
and there's been an international
conversation about this what are the
constituents of well-being and
absolutely at the top of the list our
material needs how do we meet the energy
and food and water and shelter and
material needs of people all around the
world but there's also well being
associated with access to health care
with access to education with access to
economic opportunities and to the
opportunities to to live well and to
make profits and security freedom of
want and fear and so on is it all on the
list and when we make a list like that
we can then ask how well are we doing in
that list how well have we succeeded so
far in meeting the needs of people and
there's a lot of progress that's been
made we know for example that more
people have access to more kilocalories
today than ever before so we're eating
better more people have access to
healthcare than ever before so it's a
mortality rates are in decline the death
of children under the age of 5 death
rates have declined the death rates of
women and child growth have declined
lots of indicators there and in terms of
Education you know the the literacy
rates have just skyrocketed most
children today can read so lots of
progress and maybe the best way the
best indicator for that is to look at
life expectancies at birth and when we
think about that look at the graph here
shows life expectancies as they has
changed from 1950 to 2010 in the
developed countries of the world we're
now living 80 years or longer on average
and in but in aggregate country around
the world has seen some increase in life
expectancies so that's a very good
signal but you can also see in this
graph the real problem and that is a
huge disparity between people living in
the wealthiest countries of the world
and people living in very poor parts of
the world and that disparity shows up in
a number of different areas we have
today a billion people who can't read
they're mostly adult women we have a
billion without adequate shelter or
access to safe water or to sanitation or
modern forms of energy a lot of almost a
million people go to bed hungry a lot of
times and and we're that's today
a huge challenge there but the planet is
still growing our population is still
growing so let's take a quick look at
that to get a sense for the issue so
Homo sapiens has been on the planet for
a couple hundred thousand years but just
over the last seven eight nine thousand
years we've begun to grow and it's
because of first because of settled
agriculture because of the domestication
of animals because people were living in
settlements and so by the time of Christ
we had been like 300 million people on
the planet we had grown we continued to
grow very slowly with more and more
people living in dense areas and ran
into some problems like the Black Plague
but in the 1800s everything changed our
population growth absolutely took off
incredibly quickly and it's in fact we
are still growing but we're not growing
exponentially anymore we are quite
clearly going to level off at a global
population level of 11 bill
in people or so probably towards the end
of this century or the early part of the
next that's a lot more people on the
planet that we don't have today whose
needs are going to have to be met whose
well-being is a concern for all of us
now that that population is not
distributed evenly all around the planet
and the growth and change in it is not
distributed evenly so in this figure you
can see the red line towards the bottom
is the population in the developed
countries of the world you can see
they've leveled off they're not growing
the green line shows the population
changes in the less developed countries
of the world like in this case China and
India and Indonesia growing very rapidly
at first now within a decade or two or
three of leveling off and then in the
bottom purple line you see the continued
increase in population growth in the
what are the very least developed areas
of the world the countries in
sub-saharan Africa for example so we can
look at that and see where the changes
are occurring and where people will need
the most new resources and will need to
work for well-being
the other point about this slide is that
are not in the slide actually is that a
lot of these people are living in cities
now more than 50 percent today probably
70 to 80 percent by the end of the
century and even as population if is
slowing down and stopping population
growth of stuff and consumption is
continuing is increasing and that is
good because many people right now don't
have access to enough things in the
world and many people around the world
are are moving into the middle class
so consumption will increase as well so
you look at those trends and I hope
you're all seeing huge opportunities in
this but also huge challenges how are we
going to meet the needs of that growing
and more consuming human population how
are we going
do it in a way that can be sustained
over decades and centuries and when what
does this mean for all of the businesses
in which we work how do we work towards
intergenerational well-being given this
situation
so I'm going to show you two right now a
framework that was developed and
published in this book called pursuing
sustainability it's just a primer in
this framework was intended for any
leader not not just business leaders as
a the way of thinking about the pursuit
of sustainability and at the top of the
of the framework we think about our goal
the goal of intergenerational well-being
a well-being of people here and around
the world today and in the future so how
do we meet that that's goal well through
a whole bunch of production and
consumption activities that we're all
engaged in we're creating the goods and
services and trying to provide them for
people to consume we are the actors and
agents doing that and there's lots and
lots of ways that we can do those things
better or worse that will have an impact
on long term intergenerational
well-being we could spend hours talking
through these things but what we're
going to do right now is is move down to
the underlying assets that control what
we can produce and consume we're going
to talk about five capital assets that
ultimately determine human wellbeing so
let's start at the top natural capital
this is an asset this is these are the
people of the world people in different
places it's the numbers of people their
demographics their health status their
level of education and knowledge
accumulation all of the things that
allow people individual people to be
actors and decision-makers
we have social capital those are our
rules and regulations the norms the
institutions the networks that we use
the strategies including planned
financing strategies that allow us to
move
and make decisions for sustainability
over on the other side of the graph we
have manufactured capital this is
everything we build everything we make
it's our buildings our factories the
stuff we make inside of the factories
the new technologies and tools
it's our roads and our airports and
everything else that humans make over on
the right we have knowledge capital this
is the kind of new knowledge that's
created in places like Stanford
University other universities research
centers of companies and of governments
and it's also the knowledge that is
obtained through practice and experience
in the field or in the factory crucial
to have that knowledge as we move ahead
in a transition to sustainability and
then finally at the bottom is natural
capital this is basically our life
support system it's all of the resources
that we call on in order to power that
manufactured capital and to meet the
needs of people it's the place that it's
the environment in which we live our
atmosphere our climate system and the
species and ecosystems on land and in
the oceans that provide so many of the
things that we need so that's natural
capital those five capital assets
underlie our ability to meet our goal of
well-being and the bottom line is if
they go down if we lose them or if
they're declining then we're in trouble
if our goal is to to worry about the
future as well as right now
so I would in a normal kind of classroom
environment I'd ask you right now which
of these social which of these capitals
capital assets do you think is under
most stress which one which ones are
declining and some of you would say
social capital you would say you know
without the rule of law we can't make
any progress and you'd be right others
might say well you know it's
manufactured capital we don't have the
right infrastructure to allow these new
technologies to take off and you'd be
right there too but if you're thinking
globally the answer is natural capital
globally there is no doubt that our
whole range of natural capital assets
are in decline and it's not hard to see
why if you go back to this population
growth graph and you look at that
dramatic increase we had 18 in 1800 we
had a billion people by 1924 we had two
billion people by the 1950s we had three
billion people now we have 7.4 million
and we're going to 11 if you look at
that graph and how quickly that happened
you can kind of understand why our
life-support systems have been under
stress I mean we've been in a mad dash
to meet the needs of people and we've
done that pretty well we've met needs
for energy by using biomass and most
especially fossil fuels coal oil and gas
we've met the needs of people for food
through some wonderful new technologies
that increase yields also converting
lands natural lands to agriculture and
we kept food pace the food production at
pace with human population growth we've
met the needs of people for water for a
whole range of different uses
by building reservoirs by pumping
aquifers by using water in rivers and
we've succeeded in all of these things
and many more however many of those
efforts have had unintended negative
consequences and since we didn't take
the time to worry about the impact on
natural capital so burning of fossil
fuels absolutely crucial for meeting
energy needs and yet led to is leading
to very high emissions of air pollutants
and greenhouse gases
likewise greenhouse gases methane
nitrous oxide carbon dioxide coming from
agriculture in those together add up to
a global change in temperature that
we're seeing right now there's
absolutely no doubt of that and that
temperature change is having a range of
impacts things
like very heavy precipitation events and
flooding or extended droughts or sea
level rise or increased storminess that
ultimately affect our ability to meet
the needs of people so they affect our
sustainability goals and climate isn't
the only thing there's a whole long list
of ways that our natural capital is
being degraded
and again we could spend a lot of time
focusing on the different items in this
list but I'm going to move on to say the
real challenge here is to change that
downward arrow for natural capital to an
upward arrow while still meeting the
needs of people while still paying
attention to the well-being of our
people in organizations today as well as
in the future and I think we can do that
there are fantastic examples right now
of companies engaging in doing exactly
that we'll come back to that in a minute
I want to tell you a quick story about
the how our efforts to meet the needs of
people have had unintended consequences
and then we'll go to some stories of
where things are going in the right
direction so Green Revolution the Green
Revolution took place in the nineteen
fifties through the 1990s really a group
launched by a group of academic
scientists as well as nongovernmental
organizations who recognized that human
population was growing very quickly and
there was no way we could meet the food
needs of those people without changing
the way we do things
so they created they've invested and
created a number of new technologies
improved genetic materials of the cereal
crops new ways to carry out irrigation
new kinds of industrial fertilizers new
pesticides new mechanization and as you
would recognize a lot of those new
technologies launched companies or
rather companies launched those new
technologies huge advancement there of
course the new technologies themselves
aren't were going to be enough that the
people in the field have to know how to
use them so both is that the come
and the non-governmental organizations
began to invest in human capital
training farmers in making sure that
they have the education needed in order
to employ those technologies and that
that whole system yielded a fantastic
result we were able to keep food
production at pace with that very rapid
human population growth really wonderful
but one problem was that nobody was
really paying a whole lot of attention
to the draw down on natural capital the
soil resources the effect of fertilizers
on water systems the use of water for
irrigation and over pumping of aquifers
air pollution problems greenhouse gas
emissions and on and on again changes
that affect our ability to meet the
needs of people for food in the future
so that went down there was also a bit
of a drop in social and natural capital
in some places as whole communities
whole especially indigenous groups lost
out lost their land and lost their
ability to play well since then there
all of our efforts and I'd say in the
last couple of decades have been trying
to reverse that how can we do this
differently how can we still grow enough
food engage enough companies and engage
enough individuals to to meet the needs
of people but without those negative
unintended consequences and there are
great stories I'm going to just share
one story and that is the story of a
sustainable harvest coffee importers
because I think it illustrates paying
attention to all of these assets so
David Griswold the founder in the 1980s
soon after college I guess volunteered
by working with poor coffee farmers in
Mexico and he began to see how difficult
their lives were how challenging it was
despite all their hard work for their
for their well-being to increase and he
decided later to create a business that
would help them improve their well-being
but would also be profitable so what did
he worry about he worried about
finding that knowledge capital and
creating that new knowledge that they
could employ in technologies in the
field so manufacturer capital that would
allow the farmers to get more value for
the crops that they were growing that
would allow them to reduce the cost of
fertilizers and add more of the of the
resources they had at hand including
organic fertilizers that would reduce
the environmental consequences of what
they did he recognized again that you
can have the new technologies that
people need to know how to use it
farmers were engaged were involved in
learning and training using and
improving those technologies so we
worked with the capital asset of human
capital and and he made sure and his
teams made sure that the natural capital
wasn't declining and actually was
improving because of these these
processes he also focused on supply
chain dynamics increased the
transparency of the supply chain so that
those poor farmers actually understood
where their coffee was going and who is
making money on it and and built a trust
in a long term consistency in the supply
chain that pays that back over time
ultimately producing a lot of coffee
increasing the well-being of the people
there and creating a profitable company
and the story is not over and it could
go on and on but it gives you an idea of
what one one corporation can do so I
think all the challenge for all of us is
to think about how we manage all of
these assets and their interactions in
ways that promote intergenerational
well-being and again what I would do in
a classroom situation if you were all
sitting here with us today is ask you to
apply the framework to your challenge to
your business challenge it's a it's an
in a way it's a way of thinking about
the problem it's a it's a checklist to
remind us not to forget really important
assets as we make our plans but you can
take that home and do it later so I have
to be
truthful and saying this isn't is not as
easy as it sounds this is a really hard
problem and it's because these systems
are very very complex they are not
simple linear relationships among the
different components of them so just
briefly let me say what what what is it
what a system is we talk about systems
complex systems a system as defined by a
huge field of inquiry of the system's
thinking system dynamic systems
engineering systems analysis systems
ecology are all focused on understanding
these complex systems of interconnected
elements that are that are organized in
a way that achieves something so the
boat in the picture is a system but the
lake and the the shoreline and the
rescue organizations that the boat is
surrounded by could also be considered
the system likewise your factory is a
system but your business contains supply
chains and other elements that that make
that are is it probably a better way to
think about your business business as a
system and for sustainability we have to
broaden these boundaries so that we
include the environment and the
well-being of people as well okay but
systems dynamics has focused a lot on
the challenges of understanding and in
managing complex systems and there's a
whole list of characteristics that make
a system whether it's your your business
system or anything else difficult and
I'm going to pick out just a couple of
these to illustrate a way of thinking in
a way of analyzing our decisions and
interventions so that we are trying to
assure that they're not resulting in
negative unintended consequences so let
me start with positive and negative
feedbacks I'm going to just jump into an
example here to illustrate this this is
a positive feedback cycle that plays out
in many different air
in many different organizations would
would approach sustainability of water
use in this way so we have an effort
going on at conservation of water why
are we doing this because this community
realized that it was using too much
water and their water resources were
going down and they were worried about
where they're going to get it in the
future so they started to invest in
conservation of water and they saw great
results great water efficiency results
that led to a recognition and an
awareness of the positive results which
then continue to encourage public
support for that water conservation
which then led to more conservation so
that's a positive feedback cycle that's
sometimes called a virtuous cycle
sometimes called andrea fort lien
reinforcing feedback process and over on
the right what resulted was that because
of the water efficiency results they
took less total water from the rivers
and they had more stream flows that they
could count on for the long term so
that's a great success story there seem
to work but one problem for them is that
their boundary around their system
wasn't quite route wat wide enough what
happens in this situation is that
because there was less total water being
taken from the rivers there was more
available water for new businesses and
new homes to come in and they came in it
came into the region and that increased
total water demand and that increased
the amount of water taken from rivers
and led to lower stream flows so that
was a negative feedback a balancing
feedback cycle that unfortunately led to
that original effort to increase
sustainability of water use to be not
successful these kinds of things happen
everywhere another quick example of that
this is an example it's it we're in a
community where where they're a very
underprivileged community where a lot of
people don't have access to services and
to you know schools and playgrounds and
hospice
and so forth the leaders in this area
the government the non-governmental
organizations and corporations decided
to invest in improving infrastructure
and services that led to an increase in
the well-being of the community
residents exactly what they wanted to do
and that led to more support this is a
success story and it continued
government NGO and corporate investment
another positive feedback cycle another
reinforcing one another virtuous cycle
but when others outside that region who
were still underprivileged found out
about it they saw the signs of
well-being and they moved to the region
so that they could have access to that
infrastructure and services and what
happened then is that once again that
community did not have enough
infrastructure and services to meet the
needs of the people so the positive
feedback was pushed back by the negative
feedback these kinds of feedback cycles
happen everywhere and they're they're so
common that they're there they fall into
an archetype it's called fixes that fail
you have a problem you put a fix in
place you solve the problem for a while
but then you get unintended consequences
and part of the problem is the scale at
which you're looking the boundaries that
you have around your system are are too
small and there are lots of these kinds
of feedback cycles that happen over and
over again in municipalities in
communities of all kinds in companies in
all kinds of organizations the good
thing about it is they happen so often
that there's a list of them now there's
like ten different archetypes for these
feedbacks that will get in the way of
efforts to shift towards a
sustainability goal and you can manage
for those those kinds of feedback
situations if you if you're aware of
them so this is an area that we could go
into a lot more deeply but I want to
move on
very quickly to a couple of other issues
another challenge that we run into as
we're trying to manage these complex
systems for sustainability is that
there's all kinds of connections that
take place across space and time and
there's a lot of in visibility's there's
a lot of situations where what I do as a
citizen is having impacts far far away
and I don't even realize it so in
visibilities so we sometimes get in
trouble because of that when cause and
effect are distant in time or in space
or and when solutions require actions at
a number of different scales so let me
give you a quick example of this
fascinating example that has some
solutions embedded now and that is an
example around palm oil so I'm drawing
here on on work by one of my colleagues
here Jim leap at Stanford's woods
Institute for the environment so palm
oil is a an ingredient in half of the
products in the grocery store we all use
it all the time in many different kinds
of purchases that we make if you go
through the long supply chain you can
ask the question where does that palm
oil originate from what is needed at the
base of the supply chain for that and
the answer is it comes from palm oil
blimp from palm plantations 50% of the
palm plantations in the world around
that are in Indonesia there may be
another third in in Malaysia early the
palm oil coming from Malaysian
plantations and and palm oil plantations
are also expanding now into parts of
Central and Eastern Africa and Latin
America so that's that's fine that's an
agricultural crop that is needed but
there are a couple problems with it one
is that most of the palm plantations
have were originally and quite recently
tropical forests with very often with
very heavy peach soils that have a lot
of carbon in it and as those forests are
burned to be converted in
to plantations they met huge amounts of
air pollutants and so you see pictures
I'm sure you've seen pictures of people
living in downwind cities with masks on
because they're suffering from air
pollution from the biomass burning but
they also emit a lot of greenhouse gases
and then of concern to many communities
is that they are a threat to
biodiversity there's a threat of
extinction this is a graphic from the
World Wildlife Fund focusing on a
species that is under huge stress
because of deforestation related to palm
oil so the question then is what do we
do about that how do we meet the needs
for palm oil without those negative
consequences that question was addressed
has been it has been a big problem that
has been approached very slowly over
time by but it's growing right now in
terms of the reaction so going back to
2001 a small swiss retailer my growth
got together with a couple of
conservation organisations
non-governmental organizations to create
and in any brought stakeholders together
to create a certification system they
developed a roundtable on palm oil and
they created together a set of standards
that would allow for palm oil to be
certified sustainable so that was an
important first step aim to make sense
the next step was that they then and
other NGOs came in at this point try to
engage some of the biggest corporations
in the world who source palm oil from
palm plantations and the first one to be
brought in with Unilever not
surprisingly Unilever has a long record
of social responsibility and they agreed
that they wanted to use certified palm
oil and not have deforestation occurring
and then over time many many other
players have come in there's a true
partnership among these corporations as
they seek to store
palm oil from systems where
deforestation was not and was not a
factor so that story goes on to but it's
a nice example of how partnerships can
come together to work towards
sustainability I'm going to move on past
this next characteristic although it's a
fascinating one and and and wrap this up
so we have a lot of complexity out there
as we are trying to work towards long
term intergenerational human wellbeing
and it would be nice if we could say
there's there's one great set of models
or you know simulation models or
whatever that all you have to do is is
put in an intervention and if the model
will tell you whether you're going to
have unintended negative consequences or
not the model will tell you if it's a
smart move to make or not unfortunately
no such integrated systems model
existence and if there were we probably
wouldn't believe it too complex but
there are lots of tools that we can use
this is a list of some of them many of
these are used right now by corporations
that are trying to make sure that they
have sustainable supply chains and many
more could be used in the future in our
discussions and courses here we can dive
into these with some detail and give
examples of how these different tools
are actually used to help
decision-makers make good decisions for
sustainability but the bottom line is
we're going to need a lot of humility
we're trying to do something that is new
we're going to get some things wrong we
need to be able to monitor how well
we're doing to learn from our mistakes
as well as our successes and to adapt as
we go so with that I want to just end by
saying that we in our programs here at
Stanford believe that there are three
really important characteristics of
leaders for sustainability leaders in
businesses NGOs academic institutions
government's first of all the ability to
understand these complex systems which
we've just been talking about and to
make decisions recognizing those five
capital assets the second is the mindset
in the capacity to lead in this very
dynamic world and Julian Nova Hilda slim
professor of practice here will be
speaking on this topic later in May at a
webinar and finally the ability to
design innovations that can scale that
can lead to change at a scale that
matters and professor of practice Vani
Banerjee will be giving a webinar on
that topic also later in May so with
that I thank you very much for for
listening for being part of this
discussion and I look forward to your
questions thank you well thank you very
much panel this was a fascinating
conversation and so with that I'm going
to turn it back over to town with a few
questions that have come up and so can
the first question I'd like to ask you
is we've talked about all these very
complex systems of all these activities
which industry do you think is most
meaningful to intervene in is this most
relevant to the public sector the
private sector etc what are your
thoughts on that I think I have to say
all of the applause I think there's a
role for everyone when I teach these
courses at Stanford to the up-and-coming
leaders of the future I'm basically
saying it doesn't matter where you're
going in your life you have an important
role to play in this end and whether
you're going into nonprofits or
governments or corporations of all kinds
it matters you know I think as we look
at some of the big challenges today the
meeting the energy needs of people
meeting the food needs that people are
huge and all of the industries and
corporations and companies engaged in
doing those things have a role to play I
think ultimately that example that I
showed of the the palm oil certification
program is is maybe the way of the
future I think more and more
corporations and industries are going to
be working together to try to find even
level playing fields in which they can
do good for themselves as well as
do good for the world there's no no
doubt that we're going to need a lot
more food energy water resources we're
going to have to find ways to provide
them much much more efficiently in order
to sustain for the long term thank you
so in another thread of questions that
I'm seeing come up is around the
different types of intervention or
education or activity may be needed in
first world countries or more affluent
societies and maybe third world or less
affluent societies how are the needs in
these two areas different I'm sure both
needs some kind of intervention and
education great well it's an interesting
question because I think we know
obviously in the third world countries
well let me start in this in the most
developed countries of the world we
still have lots of sustainability
challenges we have an opportunity to use
our resources to to meet the needs of
people to focus on you and well-being
much in much better ways than we are
today so it's not like we've got to
figure it out but I think what's really
interesting is to see the leap frogging
in the third world in the developing
countries of the world where companies
and corporations are moving in to to
help the citizens of those countries
those nations meet their needs through
better healthcare through more food
through better water resources in ways
that are conservative in ways that that
are smart from a sustainability
perspective that are efficient but still
meets people's needs and I think I think
companies that are engaging right now in
in in the developing world and they're
in some of the poorest parts of the
developing world are among the most
innovative because they have an
opportunity to to to innovate new
approaches that actually make sense both
for those people right there and for the
environment and for the ability for
future generations to have their needs
met so very exciting I think that's
that's the part that excites me emotion
so we've talked about the fact that
companies typically measure their
success in economic terms and early on
in the webinar we talked about the three
legs of that stool what are some
examples you can give to ways companies
have successfully used what measures
have they used to to tap into these
other components beyond the economic
value oh yeah I mean I think there's
some really wonderful case studies out
there I think if you take a look at
Unilever's 2020 living the sustainable
living program there's a wonderful list
of ways that at every scale in that
corporation they're engaging you know
from from the product design stage where
they're thinking very carefully about
reducing plastics for example or or
creating new products that require less
a new detergents that require that less
use of water those kinds of innovations
that then will go out and be actually
making a big difference to people all
around the world but then you have on
the other hand companies that are trying
very hard to manage their supply chains
so that each part of the supply chain is
actually using best practice and that's
incredibly challenging that's where
certification programs and standards
become much very very helpful but it's
they're using lifecycle assessment and
other approaches to try to to make sure
that at every stage in the supply chain
they're doing the best I can I think
that it really sustainability is
something that has to engage every part
of the company it can't just be you know
the CEO saying we should be doing this
it has to be at a CEO and the c-suite on
down committed to making it happen but
giving opportunities to everybody in the
company to use their own innovation
skills to to find solutions and many
many companies I think have done that
with respect to how they use their own
resources they reduce their energy use
they reduce water use they reduced
and they've succeeded they made money
just because of that and that's that's
fantastic but increasingly companies are
taking that perspective outside of the
walls of their own factories all right
so you've talked a lot about the
complexity of the system and how there's
so many different components to each
activity that we on do to do who is
ultimately accountable for that in the
sense of since there are so many actors
yeah well you know that I think you have
to you have to put a boundary around
your system and try to do your best
within it ultimately nobody is in
control we're talking about a global
highly interconnected system and so a
lot of this is bottom-up a lot of it is
recognizing that future well-being of
one's community one's company one you
know governmental organization or
non-governmental organization depends on
everybody doing the best thing they can
there are that's one of the reasons I
think the coalition's the partnerships
that are being developed is so exciting
because there is no government for the
globe saying you must do this it has to
be it has to come from the bottom up
that said the UN sustainable development
goals that I mentioned at the very
beginning provide an impetus for that
there they've identified really hugely
important areas that need to be solved
in the developing world and for
companies to think about those goals and
to recognize that there these are
opportunities for them to to play in an
emerging market if you will but but to
also help solve those problems that's
the exciting combination yes that's
really wonderful so I think there are a
lot of people on the line today that are
realizing that this is a very very
important topic and would like to do
more to convince potentially some others
within the organization how important
this is what are some books or some
strategies that you you would use to
help them make that argument yeah a very
good question and that's probably one
that that the next two speakers in our
we'll be able to address much better
than I yet because they're they're more
focused on on business settings than I
am I have been but that said I think you
know we used to think about training
people to be the sustainability director
or the environment director in an
organization and that's still very very
important those people play very very
important roles but we also want the top
leaders to get it and one of the big
challenges is how to engage them is one
of the reasons that we're launching this
executive education program because from
the very top we want people to
understand the both the challenge and
the opportunity for their company I
think the companies that have engaged
probably most effectively have had both
leaders at the bottom and at the top
who've worked together and they've
they've empowered their employees to be
innovative and to to engage at every
stage at every part of the organization
so it becomes an organization-wide
effort and and I think the payoff is
pretty great for those in both in terms
of maintaining and retaining great
employees but also in terms of their own
profitability and social responsibility
and I think one thing that might be
embedded in what you you said which we
should we can cause more explicitly is
really talking about both the challenges
and the opportunities when you hear of
all these different you know the growing
population and the growth and
consumption it's very easy to think
about the challenges and being a little
demoralized but I think there's also a
lot of opportunities that could be
called out as a result of that oh
absolutely and I do believe that there
are many many and corporations in the
world who see the opportunity but I'm
glad that many of them see the
opportunity not just to you know have a
have a much larger consumer base but to
do it right with that consumer base so
that there's a long term benefit as well
as a short term profit well good so i
near the top of the hour I think this
and are potentially and hopefully has
left all of you on the line with an
appetizer in curiosity to learn more
about this and to dive deeper into some
of the ways that we can actually affect
change as a result of all of the complex
challenges that we face as a species
really and as a planet and I think there
are different opportunities to do that
so as pamela mentioned there are two
webinars that will be coming up in May
that will be led by Professor Julie
innovations Hilda story as well as
Professor Benny Banerjee both of these
will be topic talking and touching in
more depth of some of these topics that
have been discussed today in addition of
course we have we invite you to join us
in September to learn more about this in
person here on campus as a reminder the
recording of this webinar will be
emailed to all of you within a week so
that you can review it again and share
with colleagues and friends and we will
also be sending some additional
information about other opportunities to
engage with us with that I want to wish
you a very good day and thank you for
joining us today